Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Sepsis is brought to you by wordpress.
My goto platform for blogging,
writing online,
creating websites,
everything.
I love wordpress to bits.
My site,
every site just about that I have is run on wordpress and the lead developer of
wordpress,
Matt Mullenweg has appeared on this podcast many times.
The very first episode in particular is amazing.
The second I took a ton of notes on,
so he's checking out,
but wordpress,
where do I even begin?
I mean the New Yorker uses it,
Jay z,
Beyonce,
they use it.
Five 38 tech crunch,
ted CNN time.
Whether you are looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
both,
neither,
something else,
you'll make a huge impact when you build your website on wordpress.com and
directly from some friends at Google.
I'm not going to quote them by name,
but they say that wordpress offers the best out of the box SEO.
That's search engine optimization imaginable,
so if you're on wordpress,
you immediately have a leg up on everybody else.
On search engines and so forth.
In my experience,
I'm no medical doctor of search engine optimization,
but I will say that I used wordpress for years and fell in love with it to the
extent that I became very close friends with Matt and then became an investor
slash advisor to automatic which runs wordpress doc on.
That is how much I believe in this and that's how a lot of my most successful
products and investments have come about because I'm in love with x and then I
seek out x.
Nearly 30% of the Internet is run on wordpress and that includes everything from
the huge sites that I mentioned to neighborhood sites and it is super easy to
get started.
There's no need to worry about security or upgrades or hosting.
They offer 24 seven support and handle all of that which allows you to focus on
creating the highest quality content that you can with the least amount of
friction.
I don't have to worry about downtime.
I don't want to have to worry about getting emergency emails if I'm on vacation
or something like that,
and wordpress is my goto solution for all of this.
I trust all of my most important text on the Internet to wordpress and they
can't buy that with a sponsorship.
They can't buy that with anything.
I want uptime,
uptime,
and quality,
and that is what I have selected after everything that I've looked at.
So check it out.
Go to wordpress,
that's w o r d p r e s.com wordpress.com forward slash Tim to receive 15% off of
your website today.
That's wordpress.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
I've used 99 designs for years for all sorts of graphic design needs,
whether you need a logo,
website,
book cover,
anything else.
99 designs was created to make great designs accessible to everyone and to make
the process of getting designs much,
much easier.
So when I first started out,
for instance,
testing,
prototype covers and getting prototype covers for the four hour body,
I want the contest drop.
That is one option.
This is a great solution.
If you're looking for fast affordable design work and the ability to choose from
dozens of options risk-free.
Let's say you need something late night,
quick turnaround,
well people in other times on other countries can also help you solve that
problem.
Since then,
I've worked with 99 designs on a separate path or a different option and uh,
that is the one to one project service.
So in x number of cases,
and I'll give you one example.
When I wanted to create the cover for my audio book,
the Tao of Seneca,
this was a very important project to me.
I decided to use their one to one project service.
And with this service you can invite a specific designer to your project,
agree on a price,
and then work together until you're satisfied and they to you to iterate and
provide feedback and all of this stuff.
And I haven't shared it yet,
but we also got some incredibly good,
really some of the best illustrations I've ever seen from using this one to one
project service with a handful of different designers and illustrators.
It blew my mind.
99 designs makes this all very easy and efficient,
so you can check out the Tao of Seneca design and other work that I and your
fellow listeners for that matter have done on 99 designs@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash.
Tim and right now you can get a free $99 upgrade on your first design.
Again,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim
couldn't tog ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers of all different types.
This episode features Kyle Maynard and you're going to want to check them out,
I promise,
and on Twitter you can say hello at Kyle Maynard,
k y.
People often ask me,
who inspires you?
Who Do you look up to?
One immediate answer is Kyle Maynard.
Despite being born without full arms or legs,
he has gone on to achieve feats of athleticism and much more than most people
would only dream of.
They might not even think of dreaming of these things.
This includes being the first quadruple amputee to climb Mount Kilimanjaro
without the aid of prosthetics being inducted into the national wrestling hall
of fame as in collegiate wrestling,
believe it and competing professionally in mixed martial.
He is just a female.
And,
uh,
we actually had a chance to do a short wrestling demo with takedowns and almost
broke my knee.
And then an arm throw on video,
which you can see.
And in this episode we cover many stories that Kyle has never discussed or
shared publicly before.
The audio comes from my new TV show fearless.
And that is fear less with less in parentheses because it's about learning to
fear less where I interviewed worth glass performers onstage about how they've
overcome doubt,
conquered fear,
and made some of their toughest decisions.
You can watch the entire first episode with David Blaine,
the illusionist and endurance artists for free@att.net forward slash fearless.
Again,
that's att.net forward slash fearless and to watch all of the episodes that are
10 of them,
including the episode with Kyle,
please visit direct TV now can as Google directv now a direct TV with one t.
So not direct TV,
but DIRECTV.
We recorded three hours of material and only one hour was used for the TV show.
This podcast episode is almost entirely new content that did not appear on
television.
So I hope you enjoy it as much as I did.
So without further ado,
here is the incredible Kyle Maynard
[inaudible].
I'm your host Tim Ferris and on this stage will be deconstructing world class
performers of all types to uncover the specific tactics they've used,
overcome doubt,
tackle hard decisions,
and ultimately succeed on their own terms.
My guest tonight is a member of the national wrestling hall of Fame And York
Times bestselling author and his summited Mount Kilimanjaro among others.
He inspires audiences around the world with this message and he congress
challenges.
But this own unique style.
Please welcome to the stage athlete,
author and mountaineer,
Kyle Maynard.
[inaudible]
how many siblings do you have?
Three sisters.
Three sisters?
Yeah.
What doesn't kill you?
Yeah,
I grew up with one little brother,
so I would as the bastard in that relationship.
I'm the leg I need to try this wrestling move onto.
You're like running around the house.
Don't run away.
I know this is going to be fun.
That was,
I was on the inflicting side.
Unfortunately there are a lot of grown men.
I'd rather fight and my sisters.
Yes.
Your Dad seems like a tough dude.
Not bad dude,
but like tough former wrestler.
I'm sure he's loving that right now.
I really like to get off.
You'll see this
in fairness,
but how were your parents parenting styles
different?
There was a difference for sure and I think it was like,
it was a good balance.
Um,
wrestling.
My Dad was like,
he wanted me to be the finesse wrestler,
you know?
And my mom was like,
she told me,
if you put somebody enough pain on the mat with you,
like they'll find a way to get out.
We'll find a way to get off of that.
And like,
that was the,
she was like,
had this like tenacity,
fuck a Cobra Kai.
Right.
It was,
thanks Bob.
When did your grandparents enter the picture in terms of your close relationship
with them?
Like hours after I was born.
Yeah,
they were there the whole time.
And what was your,
what was your relationship like with your,
with your grandparents?
I mean,
it's been the best without them.
there were everything to me,
you know,
I gotta like choke back the tears sometimes this and then my grandma's.
So she passed last year and it was really like a big moment for me in terms of,
um,
kind of like that awakener of like,
what is my life about really,
you know,
my grandma,
uh,
you know,
so she's kind of said this,
from her experiences,
you know,
in a,
like a religious background,
but I think it can be sort of even like a more universal sense if you apply
this.
Like she said that Kyle,
like God doesn't make mistakes,
you know,
like,
and I take that to go in mean to even like the universe doesn't make mistakes.
Right.
That they're in and whether or not that's true,
it doesn't matter.
But it's a cool,
it's an interesting place to come from.
Right?
The stoics talk a lot about like fate and like how we're on this path and this
trajectory and like whether or not that's true,
it doesn't really matter.
But if we go and you know,
act as if it's so,
and that things are as they should be,
it's just a better place to be.
I think I used to pray every night,
like when I was a kid.
Like I would just like,
wait,
I wish that I could wake up and have arms and legs,
you know?
And if I had spent my entire life focused on that,
it would have been a different life.
Definitely.
But she was everything.
I mean,
she,
I think that the most powerful lesson that she ever taught me was,
um,
we used to go around in grocery stores together,
just up and down the aisles of the grocery store.
And sometimes,
you know,
when a,
um,
we would meet people,
I mean,
she would just,
she would teach me,
says as soon as people hear your voice and they see your face and they shake
your hand,
they'll totally forget about the disability.
And you know,
it's like a embedded,
like hypnotic command almost,
you know?
And it's like,
that's like,
so much of my life has been colored by that everybody that I meet now,
you know,
I want to meet them and then 15 minutes after it's not really,
the disability is not like that big of the deal.
Yeah.
So [inaudible] now I can,
it's kind of
funny too cause like I can read people's eyes in terms of like,
you know,
almost like you can see like subtitles for only cross sometimes.
Right.
I go to like shake somebodies head 99% of the time we get in normal handshake
back or whatever,
if it's bump,
you know,
and then like at that 1% of the time or less,
maybe one of it,
a couple of hundred.
I see this like just fear and panic,
right?
Yeah.
You go to shake their hand and they're like pause and it's like,
guy doesn't have an arm.
What is it you wanted me to do?
And I just hang out and wait and they come in for like a awkward elbow bomb or
something like,
like,
thanks bro.
That was awesome.
It's really cool.
I like how you processed that good work.
What about your grandfather?
He uh,
my grandpa for one super smart and I did not inherit those,
uh,
those jeans.
He um,
I mean like super smart.
He was like Valedictorian and engineers like,
you know,
um,
Valedictorian at University of Illinois as an engineer.
I mean he was in with his mindset in,
in the dad.
My Dad was a engineer as well and they really,
you know,
were just great at being able to figure out ways to be able to go and adapt
different things,
you know,
and like the,
the actual tools of,
of what would be helpful problem solvers.
Yeah,
totally man.
I didn't learn to swim,
believe it or not until I was in my thirties.
When did you learn to swim?
I was,
it's funny,
I was on Howard Stern and he called my dad a dick for this,
but my dad basically put me in the middle of the pool,
taught me how to float on my back and as soon as he thought that I was like
good.
And I got it.
Then he got out of the pool and he was like,
now figure out how to get out so
we really start crying is straight to the bottom of the pool.
Right.
So it was,
but you know,
Kinda,
yeah.
I was like probably four years old,
something like that.
Three or four.
Wow.
Was the writing,
if you had writing,
eating,
swimming,
what was the most difficult of those?
And is there something else that I'm missing aside from asking girls out that
was particularly difficult for you?
The physical stuff was,
was less taxing to kind of like figure out there was any,
I kind of had this idea,
this belief like I,
you know,
that there would always be a way there'd be some tool driving in particular.
It was a little bit trickier,
you know,
is a little bit older because it was,
um,
I want to be in,
in terms of like the adaptations and equipment that I use a lot more sort of
spartan,
right?
Like I want things to be very simple,
very mechanical,
like very little,
a few points of failure.
And um,
the first vehicle that this group and amazing group that helps people with
spinal injuries in Atlanta wanted to go and how have me drive as this massive,
this massive Ford van.
And it was like this huge thing with like,
um,
it was like,
had these touchscreen computers but this back in like 2002 or three.
Right.
And so he's like touching me computers and like joystick for the,
you know,
gas,
the brake.
And I'm like,
Oh man,
this is crazy.
Right?
And I'm driving in like tiny lanes and Atlanta rush hour traffic with this like
giant death trap.
Like it was just this tank that's going down,
barely down the highway.
And I'm like,
no,
never again,
I'm not doing that again.
You know,
like not control the leading on the freaking highway.
Like there's no way.
And so I just
jack
now,
I mean,
yeah,
so they have pedals that drive just a,
like an SUV and it's just got basically lifted up and extended pedals.
A very simple,
you can pop in my car and drive it and it's like,
ah,
just put your legs underneath it.
And the,
um,
you know,
I'm using my left foot to hit the brake and my right foot to hit the gas and
grab the steering wheel with my arms.
And,
um,
my mountain guide friend actually,
who's done some pretty scary things like climbed Everest and stuff,
so that one of the scariest moments of his life was when he's driving me for the
first time.
And I grabbed my phone to like answer it.
I got,
I got to like the Bluetooth thing going now.
So like
I want to talk a little bit about cub scouts
just in general.
Just forget all these people.
I want to talk about the cups.
Awesome.
Should I join the,
I read a story about a case.
Can you talk a little bit about your experience?
Yeah,
I think this is like where I found my,
my environment.
I found my home and you know,
it was like,
like Gimley and Lord of the rings or something,
you know,
I didn't,
I,
uh,
I mean the sub training environment,
I realized it was like,
this is a great equalizer.
And so we went to this cave in Indiana as in the boy scouts.
I mean,
my dad,
my grandpa were there and um,
you know,
so you got to crawl through these tunnels and then,
right.
And it's like these tiny wet cave tunnels.
And I was like,
awesome.
Like just sprinted
past everybody,
right?
Like this is,
I don't know why it's so hard for everyone,
but
what drove you to the athletics and what came first?
I guess the street hockey,
was that sort of the first competitive sport?
I don't know.
I didn't,
so the first like a team sport that I played was,
uh,
was football on and then wrestling,
but it was like,
um,
I always had this interest in,
in sports.
I was obsessed,
you know,
and had this delusion of like,
I'd be in the NBA someday or like,
you know,
it'd be like,
uh,
you know,
as big Atlanta Braves fan and like John Smoltz or Greg Maddux,
like throwing fastballs and you know,
change ups and stuff and like,
and I think the really cool thing was,
is that my parents did let me have this,
like,
had this dream.
They didn't like squelch it.
My mom was a little more pragmatic I think.
So when I did go to play football,
you know,
she was telling me that,
you might be like,
you might be the water boy and the team,
they're gonna find a place we're in.
In my head,
like I said,
you know,
I want to be a quarterback,
I want to be throwing the spiral touchdowns.
And it was interesting how those dreams they didn't like.
And as you kind of,
I'm sure as you know,
you can relate,
right?
Like the dreams that you may have had at a certain point,
they didn't manifest exactly how you saw them go,
but it set you on this path and this journey that then takes you down another
turns and corridors and you go into other directions that you never would have
imagined before.
So the
world's strongest team start with 10 pounds,
got up to two 10 each arm.
What,
what was that?
The world's strongest team for GNC.
That was bench,
right?
Yeah.
So it was,
um,
basically I was 17,
18 years old.
It was like a,
we just kind of picked like a,
a weight,
240 pounds.
And I just did as many repetitions.
I could sort of like a combine ask kind of situation and um,
ended up at the competition.
So did 23 repetitions of that and weighed about 120 pounds at the time.
That it's just crazy because like I think,
so I opened a gym about eight years ago and,
and you know,
frequently when someone would come into the gym and like talk to me a lot of
times,
or not just me,
but one of our coaches,
they would go and point at somebody doing something amazing and then you would
go and say like,
there's no way it can go and do that.
You know,
I hear that all the time.
That's like,
to me it's like,
you know,
you have no idea where that person started.
You have no idea.
Like the massive amount of failure that went in to being able to go in and get
to that point where then they were doing something awesome.
But the difference was they stuck it out.
They did the work and then that was a result.
So,
yeah.
You know,
it's like,
I think that could go back in time and tell that 10 year old like that was
really struggling like cat someday you'd be able to go in,
you know,
lift that waiter travel world has a speaker or you know,
um,
had businesses and you know,
Gates and amazing girls or all of that.
It's just different experiences or climbs in the highest peaks in the world.
That like if I could tell that 10 year old that,
you know,
it would almost seem like like a fantasy story.
Yeah.
And I think that in coming back that question that we talked about veterans,
you know,
and,
and somebody maybe that's a really hard spot,
you know,
if they could talk to someone 10 or 20 years,
like a version of themselves 10 or 20 years later after they had really faced
some of these fears that I think that they would have their mind blown as to
what they'd be able to achieve.
For sure.
[inaudible]
you mentioned the gym,
which brings us to mind now,
I've already alluded to this.
This is like the red door knob and 6 cents.
So I'll get to my question,
which is Georgia,
why didn't you guys move to Georgia?
It was,
my grandparents moved down and this was I guess what,
sixth grade?
Sixth Grade?
Yeah.
Grandparents moved down.
I mean just like we were in Indiana and it's just the,
yeah,
was the,
I mean it was like the snow and like all that,
it was the best thing that happened I think in,
in,
in doing the moving,
going to Georgia.
But it was also like time,
it felt like the worst,
you know,
it was,
I tried to stage a family today,
Todd.
I like try to like overthrow my dad and go back to Indiana.
I know it was like I just,
I noticed that a lot,
you know,
now kind of get to sort of quasi mentor and help a lot of different kids with
disabilities and in,
I noticed that those transitory periods,
anytime like where there's a major transition in someone's life,
um,
with a move are going,
say you're going from middle school to high school or high school to college or
college to you,
like the,
you know,
the world,
then it's,
it's those periods of transition that are the most difficult and cause it's like
my friends in Indiana saw me is Kyle,
it's Omni as normal and now I've got to go in like Rhea climatized an entire new
group of people in Georgia.
Yeah.
How,
how did you,
I mean I imagine the sports is a huge tool in the toolkit for that,
right?
I mean in job rake a few dozen people,
they're like,
I'm going cows,
bodies everywhere.
It's like a war movie.
Don't mess with that.
You better be a spray.
Like so what,
what helped you in that transition?
Aside from the sports?
I mean,
what was the self talk or what did your parents or grandparents say to you?
I think they were,
they were very much my mom,
especially trying to constantly,
you know,
she was,
she's like a big,
she used to always talk about like psychosis and headaches,
you know,
and all this stuff.
Right.
She's like,
she knew she would just talk about kind of mind over matter and like just be
drilling things in.
I had,
it's like focusing on the positive and all that.
So it was really,
I'm super glad that she,
she had that perspective.
Um,
but you know,
it wasn't always the case,
but my mind didn't know.
He's obviously go there and differently.
Probably the one of the most difficult transitions that I faced was going from
[inaudible] as a freshman in the University of Georgia and write a book.
And as you know,
when you go and launch a book,
then it's like,
it changes your life pretty dramatically.
And you know,
the whole book to her and all this stuff got to be on Oprah and Larry King when
I was 19.
And it was like just like went from being a full time college student to full
time business traveler overnight.
And in my community people knew me and they knew,
you know,
not that I like the disability and stuff like that wasn't as,
they didn't make it that big of an issue.
Who would it be gone and traveling,
especially when I was traveling by myself than many people looked at me very
differently and you know,
of course they want to help and things like that.
And I've had some pretty hilarious events where it was like,
for sure I've learned that one in my,
like bigger challenges was like accepting help.
But there were some times where I knew that it would just be better and easier
if I like whatever it was,
did it on my own.
Right.
Yeah.
One time I'm in the New York airport and the RDA was a really super steep jetway
and um,
this guy,
and I get a little bit of an argument where he tells me he works at the airport
and he's telling me he has to push my wheelchair down this jetway.
I'm like,
Nah,
it's,
I'd be better.
You know better if I did it.
And he's like,
no,
I have to,
it's liability.
I'm like,
we go back and forth,
finally give in.
But this guy was like the tallest human being I've ever seen,
literally.
And he goes and takes about three steps down the jet way and he gets his foot
caught in the back of my wheelchair and he goes down.
So he doesn't just like let go.
He just launched me down and like I'm sped up and I can see that people have
their eyes at the bottom like,
this is it.
He is.
And I tried to grab the wall to slow myself down and it was like this big streak
of blood came down.
This is big CSI crime scene.
And I'm like,
wow.
And I hit the bottom of the,
you know,
we're happening all of that and like flipped out.
Sharon,
I just laughing hysterically when I'd survived.
They like,
you're like good liability coverage.
I was like,
dude,
just,
it's all good.
Never ever helped me again.
Stop helping me.
My coach used to stay after and practice and he would literally tuck his arms
into his sleeves and wrestle for my perspective.
No and try to for hours like just trying to figure out moves they could go and
do.
I think a lot of times too,
we look at things and we forget like you know,
we look at one person that's achieved something great and we're like,
oh man,
that one,
that,
that person.
Right.
And we don't see the massive amount of people,
the hundreds of people or thousands of people that have poured their life into
like trying to help that person.
Yeah,
for sure.
I read an essay by Arnold Schwartz and I recently,
which was I am not a self made man and he basically made the same point.
It's like people ask me all the time as a self made man ball,
but he's like,
let me stop you right there because you don't see these,
all of these other people,
all the other inputs,
Jujitsu come into the picture first or opening of the gym.
That shit's you came in because I saw some Gracie videos and I was like,
I want to try this.
Gracie.
They had those products and Gracie's and action and the footage of the Cheetahs
catching know
VHS nineties it was like 80 [inaudible] early days like man.
But yeah,
so I mean like that saw those videos and I was like whoa.
Like,
like even another human's able to do this to another human like I have to learn.
And I went in and I got choked out by a girl and I was like super quick to she
triangle choke me,
slapped it on.
I was like out,
you know,
and I was like wrestling club level but still like preparing to go to the
nationals in good shape.
Wrestlers love triangles,
worst,
you know,
she sees all the bad habits like,
Oh God,
I really want to demo a triangle choke now,
but we'll,
we're going to save that.
We just got our heads and we just got done.
Uh,
so the Jujitsu,
I need to do that to another human being choked people.
Yes.
Must do that.
I saw her,
this chick do this to this guy who was this girl,
what?
She did it to a guy that was like 200 pounds next day.
And I was like,
how could this,
how could this be,
you know,
did the Jujitsu then,
did you get bitten by that bug before opening the gym or was it concurrently?
What was the timeline on that?
There's a little bit before I,
but had been training for a few years and then,
um,
you know,
open the gym and actually chose to pursue a fight in MMA.
And like within a couple of months.
I mean,
it was like fast.
And so we,
um,
I had tried to do an MMA fight before in 2007 and got denied.
And so the state wouldn't commission other or the Athletic Commission wouldn't
sanction it.
Yeah.
It was the head commissioner.
He's in wheelchair actually.
He told me,
I think this is amazing what you're doing here for people with disabilities and
we support you doing this.
And then,
uh,
at a commission meeting when won't be a problem to get your license as an
amateur fight and Georgia and then like a couple of weeks before the fight,
like,
I don't know if there's a big outcry and the Internet,
a lot of people had opinions about things and said some pretty gnarly stuff.
And I mean,
my sisters were like crying,
reading some of this stuff,
you know,
people saying,
Kyle's a limbless freak show,
get doing this to get back on TV and come take a chainsaw and cut off my arms,
legs so I can get on TV too.
You know,
like the superclass of Youtube comments.
Right.
And so,
yeah,
it was,
and it was kind of my first time doing something that was very polarizing like
that.
And,
um,
it was a,
it was a unique experience and it was also coupled around my credit when the
time I had just opened the gyms and training for the fight,
uh,
you know,
and like some nights like sleeping in the gym,
I mean had opened,
opened it up and it was like coaching all the classes and I'm like the CEO,
I'm also the janitor,
you know,
somebody like goes in peaks during the workout.
I've got to go clean the toilets,
like,
you know,
so we kind of,
I mean all of those things are going on simultaneously,
trying to go and prepare for this fight,
which is like one of the biggest events in my life.
And um,
it was a wild experience,
but it looked back in that.
It was,
it was amazing.
Some of my,
my best friend is actually some of them.
One of them is here,
was a director of,
uh,
we produced documentary on it,
ESPN bought and then now it's on Netflix.
But it's does an amazing journey.
What's the doc called?
It's called a fighting chance.
Fudge.
Yeah.
So that was your first time sort of being thrown into the Internet,
Wolf,
you know,
thing or they're hungry.
Oh,
I do know a thing about that.
What did you learn from that?
Would you take away from that?
That can be,
I mean it is a really no matter what a really difficult experience.
But you also then,
I mean you have your family reading these things.
What did you learn from that?
Or actually,
and I could phrase it a different way and you can tackle it however you'd like.
If you were to give yourself advice just before getting into that situation,
what would you have said?
Have compassion for him.
Have some empathy for them and understand that like,
uh,
even,
you know,
all they're doing is they're projecting my capabilities based on their own
experiences and,
and imagining like if I were in Kyle shoes,
then of course,
you know,
like whatever,
then I won't be able to go do it,
do this or that.
And if you don't have any experience,
like if I've never trained with you or whatever,
then it would make sense that guy going into a fight.
You know,
punching and kicking is loud,
you know,
choking is loud.
All of that stuff it's like seems like crazy and ridiculous until,
um,
if we trained together I can change your perspective.
Right.
Then it's like,
so they didn't,
you know,
in their map of the world and their understanding then it was like,
I get it.
It makes perfect sense.
And at the same time in the cage,
I got to sit in there and be the first time in their looking out,
not as a spectator but as a participant.
And it was like such a cool view man.
It was like,
wow,
like 99.99% of the people that said those things would never have that view
because they're so busy talking shit that they don't live their life to then
have that experience.
And I know there's,
um,
I'm a Teddy Roosevelt thing,
uh,
a quote from a speech that he gave,
but this excerpt is called man in the arena and that I,
I really encourage everyone here.
I mean to go in and check that out made a huge impact on me,
man of the arena.
Definitely check it out.
You know what?
I also,
because I was in the middle of getting dragged through the mud at one point for
some like minor infraction on the universe.
I don't remember what it was,
but just like getting stoned to death on the Internet by some like minor
contingent of rabble rousers and I was just really down on myself and I watched
the Ratatouille Anton Ego review at the end.
I'm going to probably take us back on track but check it out.
That's awesome.
When you're in the Roosevelt and Teddy Roosevelt and Ratatouille into the
picture,
but men in the arena for sure a must read,
you're in the octagon or the cage,
what was going through your head as you enter,
whatever stands out in your memory when you're warming up and like getting
ready,
going towards it or getting in it.
Like what?
What's going through your mind?
I,
so I started before this,
like I used to like in wrestling I had overwhelming like competitive,
like you know,
anxiety and like pre match anxiety.
Like I would be overtaken by it like it was.
And to the point where I eventually want to do to know nothing about my
opponents.
And I remember like I beat a kid that was like super tough and you know,
it was like afterwards my coach was like,
did you know he was like a two time state champ and if I had known going into it
I probably would've lost.
So really going in this fight I did so much like visualization and you know,
it sounds kind of like woo,
but it was like so much visualization.
Then I think kind of like,
I felt like I told my,
my instructor,
my uh,
my Paul greatness is named my Jujitsu coach at the time.
I told him,
I was like,
I feel like I've been here like 10 times.
Like this is like my 10th or 12th fight because I had visualized it so much.
Then when I finally got there,
I was able to be calm enough to be able to enjoy that moment,
what happened to foot.
So it wasn't the most exciting thing in the world.
My,
my goal,
my strategy,
I wanted to go and cut the cage corners off to be able to,
it was a square cage that we're finding in and wanting to be able to go and then
work the angles then hit most angle or whatever it was to be able to go and
drive him against the cage and take them down.
I'm not much a kickboxer if you can imagine.
And so a lot of it in the first round is kind of beating him towards to come to
me and um,
kind of uneventful.
But by the second,
second round I was like,
press the action and pressing him,
trying to cut the corners and all that.
Didn't get him down and ate and just jabs.
Probably the hardest shot eight was maybe in the second round.
And then in the third round I was like,
screw this reckless abandon.
I'm just chasing this guy as hard and fast as I can,
like 90 seconds.
And then they,
even the announcers like,
uh,
the guy who thought it was like,
well,
this guy's on his treadmill now.
Like,
I was like more of a track of it and it was an MMA fight and I'm like,
but you know,
I'm going to go out there.
And then eventually I was like,
screw this.
Like you,
you know,
if he's not going to come in and engage then like I'm going to force the action.
I went and laid in the middle of the cage on my back and um,
he came and just crushing me on the liver and I was like,
Ooh,
bad idea.
Get back up.
Plan B,
Plan B.
But you know,
and the,
in the Internet,
it was funny,
it was like
so many people said like,
oh,
Kyle's definitely going to die.
Definitely gonna die.
I gotta turn on the TV.
It's going to be the first televised death,
you know?
It was like my other is that I was trained with Forrest Griffin at the time,
so my other training partners for us,
it was before he was going to fight Shogun,
who's like legendary MMA fighter and they were like,
Forrest is definitely at a diag and Shogun.
He ended up beating them,
but it was like,
Forrest is going to die,
Kyle's going to die.
This is like,
this camp's gonna provide the first two in the May deaths like,
you know,
but was whatever.
I didn't die unless I did and it just is actually,
this is the afterlife,
who knows?
You know,
I didn't want to have to be the one to tell him
lock where there's going to be private conference,
but
they just,
the,
the training for public exposure,
the fight itself,
by far the most valuable thing is that it's okay to have people pissed off at me
or like mad at me or saying things about me and like whatever it,
and so I was like,
okay,
I get hurt.
At first it was like a read that and I was like,
write all this stuff.
And I was like,
man,
I don't want to say that.
They didn't frustrate me.
And I remember like I wrote this post on the underground and all that stuff and
it was just like got buried and nobody even know
applied to it.
It was like this whole wave just kind of kept going.
People talking about stuff that was out of my control and I was like,
they don't know.
I want to go and show them and all that.
And I'm finally like,
you know,
I think after,
after it was done,
I was like new experience of it was like screw that.
Like I don't,
I don't need to convince everyone.
Right.
You know,
there's plenty of people that I don't need to go in and convince.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
it's just we all walk around with this idea and myself included,
we all do it right.
But I try to remind myself all the time that I don't have a freaking clue what
reality is.
I don't know.
Right.
And I want to be out in the world,
like cone kind of figure that out and just give up my assumptions and beliefs
and whatever those things are and not be tied to any one thing.
And we go and see stuff right now with like the election too and like how
polarized and everybody gets and we go and get so gripped to like these beliefs
on one side or another and it's not that one side or the other is better.
To me it's,
it's both the same thing.
It's like we have to sometimes be able to go and see that like it's just,
it's just our own perception.
It's just around percent is nothing to do with reality.
Well,
you also mentioned
in a way,
I mean something,
a piece of advice that was given to me at one point when I was getting very
frustrated and it was not about the people who don't get it.
It's about the people who do get it.
Yeah.
Don't worry about the first group and everybody has to read man.
In the arena,
it is very important reading.
It goes well with the serenity prayer and I'm not a religious guy,
but they actually go really well together.
What habits do you have?
Practices,
routines,
traditions,
anything to keep yourself positive because you're one of,
at least in interactions,
one of the most
consistently positive and enabling people for other folks.
Right.
Do you keep that going or like what are things that you find help to develop
that or maintain it?
It's,
for me,
it's like I have to have those things.
It's like going to the gym.
It's like,
it's not,
you read one book and you're done.
It's not anything like that.
I think that right now that's probably the biggest thing that I'm struggling
with in my life.
You know,
I travel close to 200 days a year and I'm like,
just,
you know,
just beat up by that and like,
it's,
so,
it's different all the time and that sort of your routine and structure is,
it's definitely something that I've wanted to have more kind of consistency,
you know?
And I think that now I'm taking the actions towards creating that in my life.
I would say the one thing that makes a difference for me is I'm actually like,
I can,
I can fake extroversion.
Well,
but I'm not,
listen,
yeah,
I'll need,
well I won't get it,
but I'll need like 20 hours of sleep I go to like fortunately not in the cards
but these,
you know,
and sometimes he'd get up and you do it anyway even when you don't feel like
doing it.
Yeah.
And that's the thing,
the difference with like a performer,
like someone that's a high performing that you have to do it right even when you
don't feel like it.
But there are plenty of times when I'm at speeches and stuff like that where,
you know,
don't you know,
I don't feel like giving a speech that day.
They get up and do it anyway.
And it's,
it's really a lot of it.
The biggest habit I think that I've been conscious of lately,
you know,
there's so much discussion and I've,
I've kind of,
I talk about this in the speech is too,
but it's like this like the idea of why,
right.
That's a big,
that's a big discussion.
I think the missing link that we have with that is there are like hundreds of
why's that are occurring simultaneously for any given moment of why you're going
to go and do anything.
Maybe thousands,
but at least hundreds.
I mean right now you could come up with like a hundred wise on the spot,
you know,
if you had 10 minutes to think about it of like why you're doing this TV show
and not to have like judgment over those things.
Some things might be business related,
some things might be making an impact on people and they'll all,
you know,
it's,
it might be just so many different inner things connected with that.
And it really,
what I've noticed is that's okay and I get to go.
And then at that point kind of select what is the one that's going to be the
most empowering place to come from with this.
In this example,
you know,
I was a young entrepreneur and reading your books and like,
looking up to you and like,
so if I come at it from this perspective of like one of the wise of me being
here,
we'd be like,
oh I want to do a good job for 10 right?
But like that's not the most empowering.
Why?
I mean that can be part of it and you can coexist with the fact that like there
may be some people in this room right now they're struggling with things that
are way more difficult than anything you or I have ever faced.
And if one thing that either you or I could go and say could make one bit of
difference with that person or people,
then that to me matters way more than anything else.
And I know that the,
you know,
all the other stuff of like,
look good on TV or like do a good job for 10 like that would be taken care of
is,
you know,
doesn't even matter.
But like if my awareness is there,
that's what matters.
And so many instances I had been profoundly impacted by,
by veterans that were also in some really rough spots.
Like I desperately wanted to serve.
I mean I wanted to go when nine 11 happened and you know,
we saw the planes go in the towers.
I was like,
I want to go bad,
you know,
sin me and would have done anything to go.
And um,
you know,
it was a high school,
right?
It stops throwing and all that.
[inaudible] okay.
So many friends that are in the military now,
some of my closest friends,
active duty,
some retired,
some injured,
some not anybody that's ever put on that uniform.
I have a tremendous respect for
and [inaudible] but
on several instances and times where I've been feeling sorry for myself,
you know,
and I mean,
I hate this word,
but motivational speaker high,
like they are motivational speakers or whatever.
They had the bad days too.
Right.
And you had moments where,
yeah,
I feel like motivating,
but then like I go in,
I meet some veterans and you know,
and just have these powerful experiences and things that like just,
just really reshaped the way they go and think about stuff.
I remember I was just sharing with,
um,
with some friends today about like,
you know,
I went in a couple of years ago,
it was a trip just back to Walter Reed and got to have to go and visit.
Uh,
we actually played the documentary fighting chance.
So we had to viewing at Walter Reed and spent about an hour in this hospital
room with this,
this one kid who had recently been been blown up pretty bad,
1920 years old.
And he was sitting there with his dad and they said,
um,
you know,
I mean,
it was fairly recent that it happened and that when he,
I was like,
invited him to come down and watch the movie with me.
And,
um,
you know,
we had maybe intimate kind of thing,
30 or 40 people in this room watching the film and like,
um,
you know,
and seeing their reactions to when the people would go and say the things that
they said about me and then I may fight.
It was like PowerPoint.
I mean there were like some of them want to strap up and show after those guys.
I'm like,
well you guys need to chill the,
you know,
so this one kid,
I remember at 15 minutes after the movie started in like he came,
he was in his chair and he'd been blown up really,
really high and it lost both legs and like almost,
you know,
where it was really high and they said that that was like one of the first times
that you got to come out of his room.
Mike,
the first time that he'd come out of this room maybe like,
uh,
maybe like one of the first times ever since you've been there.
And
okay.
Stuff like that,
man.
It's like it put a different feeling and perspective on it cause it was like it
took away the,
this idea that like I needed to go and serve with a rifle that,
you know,
but there would be ways that I could go and serve in other ways now and I'm
still [inaudible]
you know,
every fiber of my being and want to go in and find ways to go in and help those
that have been over there to defend us.
This is from Ryan Minnick
no excuses because your book was published a decade ago.
Is there anything about the book that you wish you could revise and I would just
tag onto that or add or remove for that matter.
Is there anything you'd change?
Man,
I don't think we have time
for that.
I mean really like I think a big,
I can answer that and summarize that with it's a perfect snapshot in time of who
I,
who Kyle Maynard was at 19 years old and you know,
it's,
it's not something,
you know,
at a big weakness that I've had and it kind of sec talk in a connected to what
you'd say that even like why speaking,
right.
Why am I doing that?
Well,
a lot of it frankly is,
I don't have a good answer for that because of what it's always done in many
regards.
I think that the struggle sometimes that I have now is,
is that someone will read my book and have me come in and speak to their group
and that's awesome.
But it's also like their map of who Kyle was.
His is like the 19 year old version.
And like,
I'm like my,
not even talk about wrestling.
Right.
It's like there's a lot of other stuff to talk about.
So yeah.
Do you have plans to write more books?
I do.
And I mean,
I,
you know,
I can't give you a BS excuses to why I have it.
No,
it's true.
I think that the big reason in why I have it,
I'm kind of glad that I had pain and writing is always my total actually kind of
see some of your posts.
I'm like,
that doesn't sound like a lot of fun.
No,
but it's,
it takes a lot out of you.
And at the same time I'm like,
you know,
a book is a very permanent sort of medium.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know if I'm someday if I'll have kids or not.
I have a niece and nephew,
you know,
and some need,
they'll have kids and all that.
Right.
And their kids until like way after I'm gone.
And when after you're gone,
those books will still be around is sort of a way to for people to know who you
were.
Yeah.
I always tell people and they're like,
yeah,
I really want to write a book.
Like maybe my spare time and I'm like
a mediocre book is more of a liability than a help.
Trust me.
Can't pull that one back.
Kept with the toothpaste back in the toothpaste tube on that.
It's a really messy operation.
And it's not going to work.
When you are traveling,
what does workout look like for you?
The,
the,
the pain cave.
Yeah.
How do you create that on the road?
I try to,
I mean,
I know that just with my body alone,
I can go in and make a lot of different things happen,
different bodyweight things and you know,
I mean if I have one dumbbell or something like that,
I can go and use it.
It helps for me to have like a little bit of a mat or something like that.
Kind of Yoga Mat or something that brace off of.
But generally there's some form of eating,
like any type of object,
right?
Like,
you know,
if I need to pick up this chair and go and move it around and really fast and a
bunch,
it might look really weird for anybody that comes in on that.
But like,
you know,
it's like,
I'm just imagining the cleaning lady,
right?
What is happening right now?
Am I on drugs?
Like total?
I know I gotta get out of here.
This guy,
this guy's definitely definitely on drugs.
I don't want whatever he's got,
not just making a move.
A bunch of chairs everywhere.
Worst recreational trip ever.
If you had to give a Ted talk on something that you are not known for,
do you have any pet obsessions things you geek out on that uh,
the present on Amy,
it's a little bit different,
but I would say it's,
I probably give a Ted talk on parenting,
but not from like,
I mean I'm the kids,
right?
So like who am I to talk on that?
But like,
so seeing my,
uh,
my sister as a parent is really special.
My niece was diagnosed with type one diabetes.
You know,
and Sundays are like really hard for that.
Like that's a disability that you can't necessarily always see unless you see
maybe like a glucose monitor on someone or insulin pump.
But like,
you know,
my sister's just,
I don't know,
she's just awesome with that.
Like it just is really special.
Like the other day,
you know,
they were the way,
she's at this birthday party and I'm,
this little girl came up to her and she could see that she had like a glucose
monitor in the back of her arm.
It was his princess themed birthday party and this little girl was like,
you can't be a princess because you have one of those.
And my immediate response was like,
oh well you can't be a princess cause you're the devil.
I think that
it's a fair response.
I think it's a fair response.
I think use head butter after.
Yeah,
that's right.
The little girl,
the person got it on Youtube.
Right.
It's like,
Oh make me break a jogging me and vote
the,
um,
so how did your sister handle that?
Yeah,
she's like,
she'll talk to her about it and it just like that,
just in this like very,
you know,
being open,
loving way and like,
yeah,
it sucks.
So,
you know,
and like dealing with like the reality of it,
but it's really like they,
you know,
she won't let her be consumed with this like identity around like the type one
diabetes,
you know?
And it's like,
and kind of teaching or even at a young age,
like,
yeah,
I mean if you want to do something someday to be able to make a difference with
this,
like you can,
yeah.
That's like,
yeah,
she's like four years old and then she's like the sweetest girl in my life.
I mean it,
and she's,
I think that that too,
in kind of her being around me and other things like that,
it's kind of given her a level of like,
you know,
in difference about the disability,
which I think is a really good thing.
Like indifference.
There is like zero separation.
It's just normal.
And the only time that she's ever said anything when my niece,
where we were,
um,
we were coloring together and it was this like Elsa,
you know,
Elsa and ana kind of like a thing that we're coloring.
And,
um,
and she was like,
look at me.
She was like,
Oh,
Kai,
you don't have hands.
And I was like,
yeah,
I don't.
She was like,
Huh,
it's amazing.
He's like,
wait,
okay.
I,
I love um,
tool,
right?
Maynard James Keenan and tool.
He's like,
he's the man and like,
I love him.
He also,
he's a black belt in Jujitsu.
Wrestled it army.
Yeah.
I saw a guy that tried to get on stage with him one time,
got past security and the guy was like,
went to go and give him a hug and like Maynard went to like give him a hug and
he hit Austin,
took the guy's back rear naked choke the guys like rocking out and Maynard
starts singing it again and like,
then the guys hand just drops
this bad stage throwing up on,
right.
He's,
he's a guy where I'm like,
so Maynard goes and gives up.
He's this meet music career.
He's still doing it,
but it's like he's had this super successful career in music.
Completely gives it up,
recreates himself as a winemaker.
I didn't know.
He didn't know that dude.
You're like the wine guy.
I like what
I would consumer.
I basically,
I've drank like I don't even know,
like my body weight many times over.
And now that because of you,
I thought for sure you would know that.
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean,
look,
I'm not going to,
I am capacities.
What do you know in,
in why?
No,
it's,
it's like a brutal business.
Super Brutal.
It's kind of like,
especially with,
with the exception of a rare few,
it's kind of like,
okay,
if you want to,
I can't remember.
I asked this buddy of mine,
oh,
it's a bunch of bars.
And uh,
I asked him why he didn't do restaurants.
Like,
why don't you have food on your menu?
And he goes,
I would rather he's putting to a window.
He's like,
I would rather put my hands behind my back,
jump through that window,
face first,
take all of my money and light it on fire in the street and start a restaurant.
They explained it,
but it's like,
he's kind of indifferent to it.
It's like magazines,
newspapers,
restaurants.
Like you probably should just let your money on fire.
And then wineries,
it's like,
with the exception of a handful of people,
very hard to make work brutal,
brutal.
And you're at the whim of acts of God,
right?
I mean like,
totally.
You have a bad season,
you have a bad season.
I think winemakers said the most interesting people because I think the ones
that I got to in Argentina in this last climb and we were in the land and
Malbeck and spent time with this guy,
um,
that the wine was Ellen and Nigo and had this like,
you know,
super masculine,
like half Scorpion,
half man on the label.
But it said at the end,
there's only one battle that you remember and it's a battle within.
It's like,
I'm in,
of course I'm like,
this could be terrible,
but I'm going to love it because of that.
Yeah.
But the guy was like testing limits and testing assumptions where he was growing
grapes at altitudes that like people said you couldn't do it.
Yeah.
And I love that.
You know,
it's like,
I love that you can go and test those assumptions.
It's like,
yeah,
that was,
you know,
basically it's in medicine.
It's in everything.
I mean,
I just got to give a speech with Pfizer and I talked about the treatment that my
grandma went through with this,
you know,
in cancer oncology treatment products are some of the things that they go and
make and,
and the,
the,
the polarity that occurred in,
in the detention that occurred in inside of our family and how that treatment
should go.
It was really intense.
And it finally,
I like,
you know,
she was dealing with oncologists that hadn't had,
they went to school that were like maybe 40 or 50 years ago.
Right.
And it was like there at the very tail end of their careers and they're not
updating the map.
Right.
And there's so many things like even,
um,
fasting has had,
you know,
demonstrated profound effects on,
on,
um,
you know,
radiation and chemo treatment.
That's incredible.
I mean,
you know,
Dominic D'agostino,
I've interviewed a few times of incredible scientist as looked at the effects
of,
it doesn't,
it's not effective for all types of cancer.
It's not suitable for all patients,
but there are published studies looking at how it can sensitize cancer cells,
two different types of treatments while protecting the good cells,
healthy cells.
It's very,
very fascinating stuff.
And I just want to mention one thing,
which is you were talking about how everyone has,
everyone's like Swiss cheese,
you know,
we all have our disabilities.
Just some are more visible than others perhaps.
Yep.
So malbeck this is a,
and this may be an exaggeration,
that's also common in Argentina.
Very nice people.
They love telling stories.
But uh,
Mall Beck was not really well known in the world before Argentina,
but it was brought from Europe and my understanding is that it was basically
treated like a garbage grid and then the immigrants brought it to Bueno situs
and it's turned into this world famous one that was discarded effectively.
So you never know where you're going to find the strength,
the garbage.
Great man.
And maybe that's a book,
right?
Seriously,
I think about this,
I'm like everyone
favorite societies to go and study it.
Like the Spartans and the Vikings and he's aware cultures,
they would have like left me to die.
You're right.
Take it this one,
throw them over the edge
like 300 or throwing the baby lock like that would have been me right there.
Like clearly,
oh my God.
So many amazing images coming up today.
Tingling,
Unitus.
Yeah.
I'm still thinking about your view on like coke moving your furniture.
Sure.
Uh,
well the night is young,
right?
Yeah.
The night in the night.
I mean a hell of a party.
What time you get to feel,
uh,
from when you had the initial idea to do Kilimanjaro to the point that you were
actually suited up,
geared and about to start the climb.
How much time elapsed?
So
sitting in the bathtub,
you know,
with the ice had the idea that was like fall of 2010.
Uh,
met my friend Dan,
April,
2011 and we started this project together and then April,
2011 and then by January 3rd,
2012 we were on the plane flying to Africa.
And you have to figure out a lot of stuff.
I mean,
first it was getting somebody that's crazy enough to take us seriously because
it was like,
so how'd you convince someone to do it?
Um,
it was,
it was rough.
I,
and when we,
I think so,
thankfully one of my friends and mentors,
this guy named Eric widen my or that,
um,
this is the first blind mountain near to climb Mount Everest and every high peak
in the world.
And he actually just rafted the entire length of the Colorado River through the
Grand Canyon.
Wow.
Right.
Not rafted like on a rafting,
kayaking.
Why?
Wow.
Completely glass,
like,
not like a peek through,
you know,
when you like put blindfold on a little bit,
like he doesn't,
it's like crazy to think about that.
That's wild.
And like,
he's insane.
He's amazing.
And,
um,
you know,
I,
I saw like sought him out.
Me and my friend Dan who helped me cocreate the mission and,
um,
we,
you know,
Dan was the first one that was kind of like the one crazy enough to go along
with me.
Um,
he'd,
you know,
he'd been a record setting,
Middle Linebacker,
Eh,
the Alec was,
you know,
he was like five foot nine or something like that,
and like had 21 on us is tackles in game.
If it was like one of the most,
you just passionate,
esoteric,
you know,
just guys that we and I can connect with on that level,
almost burnt my house down because you know,
a couple of screws,
literally random story.
But yeah,
you like microwaved an aluminum coffee mug and I was doing some emails and I
turned around and there's flames shooting out of my way,
like Brown.
So I hope he sees this,
but you know,
so it's like,
but he's this kind of guy though that was like she could go and run through a
brick wall.
Yeah.
And I needed that person to go and have that belief with me.
So then from there we sought out Eric,
Eric introduce this to our guide.
Kevin [inaudible].
Kevin had led now he'd managed out Eric's base camp,
um,
of,
of Eric.
Eric saw Everest climb,
this base camp manager.
He led,
he's led more climbers up Kilimanjaro than I think any American and many with
disabilities.
Let a guy almost to the trees on it and like a hand crank bike,
um,
group of like eight climb,
applying climbers up Kilimanjaro.
So with Kevin,
he was really the one that,
you know,
him and his partner Kristen and kind of made it happen.
Well I would just want to thank you Kyle for honestly showing everyone that they
can do more than they think they're capable of doing.
It's a huge gift to the world.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short,
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
I've used 99 designs for years for all sorts of graphic design needs,
whether you need a logo,
website,
book cover,
or anything else.
99 designs was created to make great designs accessible to everyone and to make
the process of getting designs much,
much easier.
So when I first started out,
for instance,
testing,
prototype covers and getting prototype covers for the four hour body,
I want the contest drop.
That is one option and this is a great solution fueling for fast,
affordable design work and the ability to choose from dozens of options
risk-free.
Let's say you need something late night,
quick turnaround,
well people in other time zones,
other countries can also help you solve that problem.
Since then,
I've worked with nine,
nine designs on a separate path or a different option and that is the one-to-one
project service.
So in a number of cases,
and I'll give you one example,
when I wanted to create the cover for my audio book,
the Tao of Seneca,
this was a very important project to me.
I decided to use their one to one project service.
And with this service you can invite a specific designer,
do your project,
agree on a price,
and then work together until you're satisfied in their to iterate and provide
feedback and all of this stuff.
And I haven't shared it yet,
but we also got some incredibly good,
really some of the best illustrations I've ever seen from using this one-to-one
project service with a handful of different designers and illustrators.
They blew my mind.
99 designs makes this all very easy and efficient,
so you can check out the Tao of Seneca design and other work that I and your
fellow listeners for that matter.
I've done on 99 designs@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim and right now
you can get a free $99 upgrade on your first design.
Again,
that's 99 designs.com four slash Tim this episode is brought to you by
wordpress,
my goto platform for blogging,
writing online,
creating websites,
everything.
I love wordpress to bits.
My site,
every site just about that I have is run on wordpress and the lead developer of
wordpress,
Matt [inaudible] has appeared on this podcast many times.
The very first episode in particular is amazing.
The second I took a ton of notes on,
so he's checking out,
but wordpress,
where do I even begin?
I mean the New Yorker use it,
Jay z,
Beyonce,
they use it five 38 tech crunch,
Ted,
CNN.
Time with you are looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
both,
neither.
Something else.
You'll make a huge impact when you build your website on wordpress dot calm and
directly from some friends at Google.
I'm not going to quote them by name,
but they say that wordpress offers the best out of the box SEO.
That's search engine optimization imaginable,
so if you're on wordpress you immediately have a leg up on everybody else on the
search engines and so forth.
In my experience,
I'm no medical doctor of search engine optimization,
but I will say that I used wordpress for years and fell in love with it to the
extent that I became very close friends with Matt and then became an investor
slash advisor to automatic,
which runs wordpress.com that is how much I believe in this and that's how a lot
of my most successful products and investments have come about because I'm in
love with x and then I seek out x.
Nearly 30% of the Internet is run on wordpress,
and that includes everything from the huge sites that I mentioned to
neighborhood sites,
and it is super easy to get started.
There's no need to worry about security or upgrades or hosting.
They offer 24 seven support and handle all of that,
which allows you to focus on creating the highest quality content you can with
the least amount of friction.
I don't have to worry about downtime.
I don't want to have to worry about getting emergency emails if I'm on vacation
or something like that,
and wordpress is my goto solution for all of this.
I trust all of my most important text on the Internet to wordpress,
and they can't buy that with a sponsorship.
They can't buy that with anything.
I want uptime,
uptime,
and quality,
and that is what I have selected after everything that I've looked at.
So check it out.
Go to wordpress.
That's w o r d p r e s s.com wordpress.com forward slash Tim to receive 15% off
of your website today.
That's wordpress.com forward slash temp.